this is not a partisan issue it's not
about being right or left politically
it's about a basic fundamental
constitutional right hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer freezing TV and today we're
here with the Reverend Rick Hoyt from
the First Unitarian Church of Los
Angeles Reverend thanks for being here
thanks Tracy it's good to be here so
right now you've joined forces with the
Electronic Frontier Foundation and 19
other organizations to sue the NSA for
overreach of electronic surveillance and
there's a number of these lawsuits
floating around right now so could you
talk about your specifically and why we
should pay attention to it well the
argument in First Unitarian Church vs.
NSA is a particular argument focused on
the First Amendment several of these
other cases have been brought on 4th and
5th Amendment rights the First Amendment
though guarantees a person's right to
free assembly the reason that the
collection of plaintiffs on the the
First Unitarian Church vs. NSA lawsuit
are so broad is that the Electronic
Frontier Foundation is trying to make
for the legal point that this is not a
partisan issue it's not about being
right or left politically it's about a
basic fundamental constitutional right
and so the 19 plaintiffs are
organizations who have legitimate
reasons to fear that persons who would
like to associate with our groups might
be afraid to have phone call
communication with our organizations
because of the NSA surveillance and
therefore by associating with our
organization they then might attract
that government attention on themselves
so it infringes with our ability as a
church to attract members and infringes
with our members ability to freely
associate with an organization of their
choosing the Unitarian principles
religious principles have to do with
ensuring justice and equality and
liberty for all people and we do think
that is part of our religious work in
the world to move out into the public
sphere my church has been heavily
involved in political action throughout
the the rest of the 20th century and up
to the current day can you talk about
your church's activism in the 50s in the
1950s of course we all remember it was
the the McCarthy era there was a lot of
anti-communist hysteria going on and
here in Hollywood actors and writers
were being blacklisted for presumed
communist affiliation and
my church took a very public and
courageous stand on supporting people
who were being harassed by the
government because of their political
beliefs our own minister was hauled
before the house on American Activities
Committee and was interviewed by them
our church stopped keeping a membership
list during the 1950's because people
were afraid of signing on to an
organization that was under surveillance
by the government so that's a very
relevant piece of our history to the
current situation so talk about this
chilling effect a little bit more I mean
the NSA has said we're not recording
actual conversations well that is a
common defense that well we're not
actually looking at what you're saying
or listening to what you're saying in
the phone conversations but there's
still a lot of information you can gain
about a person just from noticing who
they're calling and how often they call
and how long the phone calls are which
is all information that the NSA is
collecting so for instance if I have
someone who's interested in becoming a
member of our church and they're calling
the church for you know six or seven
times over the course of a couple of
weeks and then my church is calling the
back for a few times it's pretty
reasonable to infer that that person is
looking to to assemble to associate with
my church and if they were are afraid of
making those kinds of phone calls or
receiving phone calls from the church
then it might definitely have this
chilling effect on them making them
reconsider their actions of joining my
church you're coming to the church even
not as a member but just for programs
what's the timeline right now I mean the
eff just filed the eff has several cases
including some other cases working on
this particular piece of public policy
some of which have lasted already
several years there does seem to be a
heightened interest and a little more
momentum in the last couple of months
having to do with Edward Snowden the
issue is now public enough and enough
people are aware of what's going on and
there's even voices in the in the
government them cells that are beginning
to question how far the administrative
Department has gone that will probably
see a legislative change that will solve
some of these issues before this court
case would go all the way to the courts
mandating a change so that's my hope
we've been talking with the Reverend
Rick Hoyt from the First Unitarian
Church of Los Angeles Reverend thanks
again
for being here thank you very much good
to be here freezin TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer